so this story uh that i'd like to share
is the downside
of analyzing with a chess genius i got
tons of bobby fischer stories
and this one comes courtesy of robert
byrne and robert
tells me the story of the havana
chess olympiad 1966
where he's playing on the american team
and the american team is being led by
none other than
robert james fisher bobby
was the only one on the team who had a
suite in the evenings the whole team
would
congregate together at bobby's suite and
they'd replay
the games that they just played that
afternoon in the olympiad robert was
saying this was really the highlight of
the olympiad and everybody on the team
would scramble to get to bobby sweet
because bobby
would show the game he played and
analyze and explain
what was going on these lectures these
moments
were just absolutely absolutely awesome
so bobby is showing a game that he had
played that day
somewhere as bobby is moving the pieces
and explaining
he then in a derogatory way
calls his opponent a pizza and he goes
and the pizza played this move and as
he's making the move
bobby starts chuckling and laughing and
then kind of laughing
really really hard the kind of painful
god
i think
he literally
falls off his chair on the carpet going
back and forth rithering an absolute
joyous abandonment laughter
about his opponent's moves the five
grand masters on the team
are looking at the position because the
pizza
played a reasonable move
and they couldn't understand why bobby
was laughing
nobody saw the reputation
and robert was in a panic
an absolute stone cold
panic
because
he's laughing and robert doesn't see why
bobby's so
so incredulous about isabel
then
bob sees the reputation of the book and
bob starts laughing
and then collectively around the table
all five see the move
bobby who's now in tears just barely
makes it back to the table and makes the
move
that robert byrne anticipated and boom
boom boom boom and bingo bongo so robert
tells me the story decades later
that he was an abject terror
he would not have seen the move
and that bobby would realize that
nobody's seeing the move and kick
everybody out and think of them as
potzers too and robert did not want
bobby fischer thinking he was a weak
player so the moment he saw that winning
move he said
the relief that i felt
was almost the taste of honey